I just hold a little bit of Mario about
my story started watching Valley
taymiyah a long long time we don't like
before I was making like a decent amount
of money so maybe like from zero to list
this month so far three hundred thousand
revenue you send me a video of yourself
right leaves you that's me when you send
it to me you read 56,000 yes that was
like three hundred thousand yeah this
guy went from value Tim is zero to fifty
six hundred three hundred in one month
you three hundred one month this month
great job and I'm probably yeah good for
you so it's been a long trip
yeah Josh oh yeah starting from watching
like six eight months ago okay now so
let me ask you from the moment you
watched by you tender when did you start
your business I would say a month after
watching so you watched by he came in a
month later you started your online
income
ecommerce business how long did it take
you to get you there was a number you
gave me 40 mm give me another number 56
56 thousand and then went to 70,000 and
then a hundred last month like two
months ago was 156 thousand this one is
so far thirty thirty thousand three
hundred thousand
twelve thousand so it's like it's you
look good eighteen years old goes from
zero to fifty six and three four months
and then three hundred thousand dollars
in a month you ought to be very proud of
yourself let me tell you this
I love seeing young guys like you who
are focused determined and no excuses
you're somebody that made a decision no
one told you to do it and you took your
business stage this is a point like I
remember you would say you sent me one
time like a 6-part yeah like a message
I'm like what is this guy saying any was
saying mr. BAE David I want you to know
here's what I'm doing this is my
business then I'm doing this then I'm
doing this this one we did this my goal
is to get to this very detailed